en revenant de l'école par tour et
charlotte se précipitent pour regarder
la télévision
quel est ton poste préféré la nuit
tombée papa et maman regard de netflix
mais aussi l'extra de tou.tv je te sont
portés à écouter des trucs québécois
j'aime bien la semaine verte parce que
je suis très engagé en environnement ma
conjointe est restée tout pointe et moi
j'veux plus netflix
visiblement les habitudes changent et la
télévision est en pleine transformation
même si 80 % des francophones ont
toujours un abonnement à la télévision
conventionnelle 49% ont aussi un
abonnement un service de télévision en
continu
l'offre de contenus explose le fait
tellement diffuse et les gens savent
plus quoi choisir veut pas voir 1006 un
poste puis pas savoir quoi regarder oui
une guerre de prix c'est sûr qu'ils se
préparent des joueurs comme dessinée à
pau et hétéros qui rentrent sur le
marché pour atteindre leur seuil de
rentabilité doivent aller chercher entre
60 et 90 millions d'abonnés puis on pas
dix ans pour faire seuls sept géants de
la télévision en continu s'affrontent au
canada dans le coin droit
le numéro un netflix se fait
concurrencer par amazon prend une vidéo
par crève et nouvellement par rapport tv
+ et 10 n'est plus dans le coin gauche
il y a les grands spécialistes de
l'offre francophone club illico et
tou.tv
là on rentre dans une nouvelle ère de la
guerre des plateformes qui va être celle
du contenu exclusif et bien évidemment
on peut se réjouir pour les
consommateurs les spectateurs comme ça
mais en même temps ça entraîne l'autre
question qui est celle justement de
comment combien qu'on paye pour avoir
accès à ces différentes plateformes
pour le consommateur la facture peut
grimper assez vite à un abonnement à
tous les services représentent une
coquette somme quelle est la capacité
des gens pays
ici au canada par exemple deloitte
prédit que ça va être autour d'une
centaine de dollars par mois pour des
abonnements de contenus médiatiques
confondues loti radio les journaux
l'audiovisuel ecce terra
donc les gens vont devoir faire des
choix laissé serment c'est ce qui va se
passer
absolument il va falloir qu'il fasse un
arbitrage et décider choisira quels
services ils vont s'abonner
c'est pour ça que je prédis en fait
qu'il va y avoir beaucoup de
fluctuations journée le nerf de la
guerre c'est le contenu original le
klube illico et tou.tv mis sur les
émissions à français et ils ont vu leur
nombre d'abonnements grimper en augmente
notre offre on augmentait beaucoup notre
offre de contenu autant sur le gratuit
que sur le paye en offrant des web
séries en offrant beaucoup de produits
québécois en offrant des primaires sur
notre plateforme
il ya aussi plus de gens l'offre de
contenu pour le club on perd de 6000
conduit et autour de dix mille heures de
contenu de divertissement donc c'est
quand même une offre une offre très
alléchante pour nos clients de retour
sur les dix ventes
arthur et charlotte ont droit à un
véritable buffet de contenu télévisuel
mais leurs parents les ont alors eux ils
écoutent très important quand même comme
parents de contrôler le temps des côtes
justement pour moi c'est quelque chose
auquel je tiens vraiment beaucoup parce
que ça a un effet sur le cerveau des
enfants donc il faut un contrôle
judiciaire vous êtes à peu près quatre
ans et de saveurs 39-45 moniteur in par
jour malgré l'arrivée de disney plus
pour l'instant
la petite famille il n'entend pas
s'abonner à plus de 2 services de
télévision en continu
ici louis fait de prime radio canada
morin
[Musique]